everyone knows that 0 * anything equals
0 but why your intuition is probably
telling you that multiplication is
repeated addition and if I add zero
copies of something then of course I
have zero things if you have a bit of
math knowledge you might go beyond
intuition and say that's just how
multiplication is defined 0 is the base
case 0 * anything equals 0 and
multiplication of larger numbers is
defined by saying y + 1 * x = y * x + x
but we use the symbol 0 for a lot more
than just the natural numbers 0 the
natural number * anything equals 0 0 the
real number time anything equals 0 0 in
modular arithmetic time anything equals
0 the 0 Matrix * anything equals 0 the
constant Z function time anything equals
0 and even the zero function convolution
anything equals z these are all
different types of zeros and different
types of multiplication they're
definitely not simple repeat Ed addition
and yet we still end up with 0 *
anything equals 0
why let's prove it and see what about
zero actually makes this
happen start with the expression 0 * X
for now you can assume these are real
numbers but we'll see shortly that's not
necessary 0 is 0+ 0 because 0 plus
anything is that thing then because
addition distributes this is 0 * X Plus
0 *
X and this point in the proof we don't
know that 0 * x equals 0 but we know
that it's some number and we know that
number has a negative so let's add that
negative to both sides of the
equation then group with parens and
since a number plus its negative is zero
we get 0 = 0 + 0 *
X and since again 0 plus anything is
that thing we finally arrive at 0 * x =
0 in this proof the only facts we really
used are that 0 plus anything equals
that thing that addition distributes
over
multiplication that every number has a
negative that cancels it to give zero
and if you want to be real technical we
did also use associativity to group
forends we don't even need commutativity
of addition or multiplication which is
good because matrix multiplication is
not
commutative if you're applying for grad
school you might describe this as the
identity for an associative invertible
operation is absorbing for any other
operation that distributes over the
first
that's why it works for matrices
functions convolutions and many more
because all these types of objects
satisfy common axioms which in
particular include the properties we
need and no this does not prove that 0 *
Infinity equals 0 the proof only works
if 0 * Infinity is defined so that we
can do Algebra on it but 0 * Infinity
isn't defined so no
proof although if you're a teacher it's
a fun exercise to ask your students to
explain why the proof breaks down for
Infinity
anyway you're probably wondering well
what about those assumptions is there a
similar trick to show that 0 plus
anything equals that thing it feels like
a very similar kind of problem usually
this is just shown manually because the
behavior of zero under addition is
closely aligned to the definition of
addition itself a lot of the time you
give the label zero to an element of
your number system precisely because it
has the property that it does nothing
under your addition so maybe the real
question is how do we normally Define
addition at all great question maybe a
topic for another video thanks for
watching as always thank you to my
viewers who support the channel through
patreon and other forms of donation slap
that like button an odd number of times
and I'll see you in the next
one